it's really quick uh what is your name
sir Jesus
what's your last name
do I have two answers bro answer what's
your last name
yes sir at the moment yes sir
you don't remember your last name no
okay how old are you do you know your
date of birth
but remember just lean against me and
just lean against it right there I don't
want you to fall was there anyone else
in the vehicle with you it was just you
right now we'll go ahead and check up on
uh paramedics we'll check you off okay
so what's your
see you you don't remember your last
name
what's your date of birth December
December what
you don't remember
wherever you're going to
go home what's your address
you remember your address
where were you coming from from home
from home and you were going home
so where's home
is that word that way in San Juan all
right right now
[Music]
so what's your address inside one
you don't remember
so if you were going home then where
were you coming from
[Music]
anything hurt
hurt
what's everything
my nose hurts my arms turned my legs
hurt my knee straight everything hurts
awesome you're awesome you guys are 43
no I'm not there as well
come right over here sir
come right over here
just stand right over here in the back
but what's your last name Bruce
all right another one check you out just
do me a favor
what's your what's your date of birth
first
I'm from 98 all right and where's your
house
[Music]
veterans veterans okay do you know the
address
I don't know the address how long have
you have you been living there
okay where is it by yeah
[Music]
and where are we going
right now
all right now
oh
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I'm gonna check your checking your eyes
sorry do me a favor just
try to put your feet together I know you
set your foot hurts you just try to put
your feet together okay now we'll go
ahead
all right do me fair just look right
over here man let me figure it I'm gonna
be checking your eyes look at the tip of
my pen with your eyes only
all right just just stay still not move
around all right just okay I'm gonna be
checking your eyes okay
keep looking at the tip of my pen with
your eyes only
[Music]
yeah
come on come over here
all right come here come come stand
right over here
do not move your head
it hurts bro okay okay I'm saying but
this will take just a little bit it's
gonna be quick
with your eyes only man
with your eyes on
it
look at the tip of my pen with your eyes
wow
with your eyes only do not move your
head
do you understand
do you understand yes all right look at
the tip of my pan with your eyes on me
yeah
look at the tip on my phone with your
eyes
yeah all right keep your hands to your
side
keep your hands on your side
on your side the trans on your side
right there
unfortunately
stop moving
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you gonna are you gonna look at the
tip on my pen I'm looking at the plan it
just hurts all right ambulance is coming
keep your hands to your side
look at the top of my pen because
all right that's all I need you to do
look at this only
2015.
foreign
how many have you had to drink
all right
do the driver
s over the car
[Music]
Hey sir come on right over here
my Vegas
right there
[Applause]
[Music]
I was trying to complain
what what is what hurts all right
fingers or be specific what you said
your foot and what else my body hurts my
body where in your body my nose my face
my back okay
yeah are you just gonna ask him about
hers I don't know what find out what oh
fuck
for the hospital
they're uh EMS already
right now there we're just waiting on on
EMS to get here take you to get checked
out
for work make sure you're okay your body
hurts it hurts but I mean if y'all
didn't let me go I mean it doesn't hurt
you know
are y'all just trying to let me suffer
you know that's why we're saying we're
bringing you EMS so you can get checked
out so while we're standing here then
because we're waiting we're waiting a
mess
several people that got hurt man inside
the house yeah
we gotta Gotta Wait for more I'm trying
to get them here faster
[Music]
[Applause]
brakes
earlier
take a seat take the seat you're gonna
fall almost
yeah they're here
you walk that way
up that way they're just gonna charge me
for the hospital well we gotta go to the
hospital
actually
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
check you out
make sure everybody
I understand but I don't have money to
fucking spend on fucking ambulances
so you don't care about your well-being
[Music]
you want to make sure you're okay
you guys getting paid you know
we are okay all right away we're here to
make sure you're okay you're not getting
paid to make sure you're okay we're here
not too sure that the EMS is going to
take me one they want to take it to the
hospital to get you checked out make
sure you're okay
you don't know you never know you might
have something internal
you said your foot hurts your face hurts
your nose hurts it's so hard
and you have you have blood on your nose
also
it's just a bloody nose
[Music]
so how long ago we coming over were you
going home
like what was the time you were going
home you know
remember
huh
are you guys going to cover it like the
hospital
so what if I don't want to go we're
still gonna have to go man yeah
[Music]
against you
so if I want to go with you it's going
to do arrest me yes I guess my will go
for DWI
against me
get against my water I guess you can do
that hold on I'm telling you defensive
do I want to talk to you
as it is right now
[Music]
on the ambulance
do you guys didn't take any budgets
right yes
take me to the hospital
yeah you don't want to go in the
ambulance
shit right you're under arrest as it is
already so the only option we're giving
you is whether you go to the hospital in
the ambulance or you go in the hospital
with us yeah I mean they're regardless
shit right they're gonna regardless
I'll go to the ambulance
all right just wait for the
huh
[Music]
should get checked out because it's
really we're involving a major action
right now you might not feel because
you're better than this real high you
know what I mean I mean
now what is you guys concerned the
things that inflation for the rest
because
so I need to get you first medical
attention
to take you to the hospital
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go
right to swim
right over here right over here
wait I'm gonna go ahead and
search your pockets you have anything
I'm gonna poke me stick me all right go
ahead and go ahead and get closer
[Music]
right there
right there right there stay there
it hurts
all right just just stay there still
there I'm going to keep checking
yourself do you have anything else
all right
[Music]
what
is it down
[Music]
I'm hungry
let's stay there I'm gonna go ahead and
put your seatbelt on
order
your arm
both of them all right just do me a
favor just stay there right now when we
get over there
I'll go ahead and check them out like
put your leg in I can't
what's up
my arms in bro what's up I can't have my
arms
no no put your put your leg in I don't
want you to hit the door yeah bro I
can't I can't wait
all right there you go
oh fuck what's up that shit hurts bro
don't don't move your arm
you're moving your arm it's gonna
hurt
I need you to sit down huh
you'll be able to take these off no I
can't take those off right now
I think I'll go over on the other side
[Music]
ah of course
all right let me go and put both of them
[Applause]
[Music]
watch your step all right I'm gonna go
and put two of them so maybe it'll help
you out hey there
[Music]
yes
all right come here give me your hand
give me your hand
I'm gonna go ahead and loosen it
oh
[Music]
we're ready go in
shouldn't be that bad
[Music]
boys sit down property
all right watch it
oh
did you sit down properly I'm trying to
bring
it man
I don't know what else to do and see
Captain I can't hook you up
I can't help you up
can you move a little bit more that way
no the other way
thank you
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]